[Music]
these were the last few moments of
Winston ragussis life before he was shot
dead by police they say the former
soldier refused to follow their orders
and was threatening to shoot them so
they fired the tip twice but witnesses
deny this
they say he posed no threat to anyone
his family says rago's was suffering
from post-traumatic stress disorder and
his death is a huge loss for them he was
very thoughtful especially to his nieces
and nephews he remember there were
birthdays and he was a very generous man
other videos that critics say show
excessive use of force by police have
gone viral - in this one a police
officer forcefully tries to arrest a
foreign national during a dispute over
quarantine measures imposed by the
government and here another officer
appears to break into a private
condominium before threatening to arrest
people using areas like a swimming pool
the Philippine government has placed
around 15 million people under lockdown
across the region of Luzon to clamp down
and the spread of the corona virus
that's nearly half of the country's
population just a few weeks ago
president rodrigo duterte ordered the
military and police to shoot dead anyone
who creates trouble
police have denied allegations of
wrongdoing and say they have arrested
more than a hundred thousand people
since the lockdown was implemented more
than a month ago Human Rights Watch has
issued a statement urging the government
to investigate reports of abuses and
hold officers who have committed rights
violations accountable
communities really been subjected to
very harsh regulations without regard to
the realities of their situation and in
that is going to result in a lot of
anger and frustration on the part of the
communities the government says its
policies are necessary to fight the
spread of the corona virus but people
here tell us the use of what they say is
a heavy-handed and violent response by
police is creating fear and anxiety
Jamel Allen dog and al jazeera Manila